[Music]
in good parenting news
yeah it's emitted by Wes with the chest
mother of two CEOs and a doctor give
advice on parenting successful chips say
no to CEOs and a doctor that means you
just raise some psychopath yeah we've
come up that's like underachieving
though for an Indian family follow me
yeah verage the [ __ ] two failures and
a doctor yeah two CEOs what do they see
you up if it's not a billion-dollar
company nobody cares I'm the CEO of my
own S corp who's right okay there's only
one person in the company it's me in
every email I put CEO of David o
Combinator joke the mother Susan
Wojcicki who's the CEO of YouTube
channel jetski who's a co-founder and
CEO of 23andme and Janet what's really a
professor at University of San Francisco
so it's the mom they're huge
take back I'm ready to listen are they
they grew up in NorCal right I think so
I'm ready to listen to what she has to
say let's do it yeah
so she says that her entire parenting
style is off of these values that she
calls trick so it's trust respect
independence collaboration and kindness
this is a conflict of interest by the
way that's too easy
this is a conflict of interest cuz we
shouldn't be interviewing the parents we
need to interview the kids exactly
they're not pieces of [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] are your kids huh loss of health
and how happy they are throughout a
botched room so she wrote a book that's
a good point
thank you for cuz I agree I want to hear
from the kids too so she wrote a book
because a lot of people would always ask
her like oh you know like how did you
raise such successful children and so
her book is called how to raise
successful people simple lessons for
radical results my Estero jetski Oh cuz
that's the mom of the other two the
three sisters of two CEOs and the doctor
seems like yeah capitalize on children's
success she tricked us everyone got
tricked it's just a family what did
stand for trust
so trick is trust another one for price
is down the street
trick effect independence collaboration
kindness so I could break it down what
she says for each one is doing well
first let me show a quote all her
daughter's also another term for
prostitute I'm freaking out
yeah these are all the sisters I don't
they didn't know that they were
protected that's why they were so
successful they didn't know prostitution
it was this is I don't know what a trick
is yeah you [ __ ] trick trust right
it's that she right I also got some back
I got some extra questions from the
investigative person how many total
children did she have cause if Jeff
didn't eat children won three out of 50
that's a bad percent I bet you they have
a little David so two in that family
they're just not showing the runts is
there gonna be 47 failures we didn't
know the statistics we just want to find
a hole in this there's a lot of agents
here we want the numbers trick this is
what you do I believe she'll water use
three kids 100%
three four three here's the trick you
have a lot of kids and make them compete
against each other for your love and now
they're damager for the rest of their
life they don't know what they're
competing for but they always need to
chase something let me tell you the
breakdown of what you're right so Trust
is she says we are in a crisis of trust
the world over what we are in a crisis
of trust the world over sorry I couldn't
read parents are afraid and that makes
our children afraid to be who they are
to take risks to stand up against
injustice Trust has to start with us
when we're can confidence in the choices
we make as parents we can then trust our
children and take to take important and
necessary steps towards empowerment and
independence
she said that from the moment her kids
were born from babies she always treated
them like adults
I refuse I agree that's why we got to
stop baby talking we don't baby talk
yeah tige I just say baby talk with each
other yeah but your brains are developed
now now you know this [ __ ] that we say
to each other when we turn the ars into
double these we never do that with Tyga
that's good because I read that that
actually slows development
I won't just my kid slang man
good morning blood fishin
alright so forest bench she writes the
most fundamental respect we can show our
children is to she is toward their
autonomy and individuality every child
has a gift and is a gift to the world
and it's our responsibility as parents
to nurture that gift I agree it's
beautiful this is the exact opposite of
telling kids who to be what profession
to pursue so she's so anti-asian
parenting right two billion people on
this planet that would disagree with
saying it's about supporting them as
they identify and pursue their own goals
that's so nice I have a question as
she's reading this I'm now thinking
about my own parents and seeing if they
fit the small and they suck it sounds
like they have they have but there
should be one last category called
ass-whooping yeah where you get your ass
beat
waiting for jack Ma's parents to write
some [ __ ] but I'll get there so first
let me tell you independence and what
she writes about that
so in the pitman don't help them out at
all independence relies upon a strong
foundation of trust and respect children
who learn self-control and
responsibility early in life are much
better and lucky are much better
equipped to face the challenges of
adulthood and also have the skills to
innovate and think creatively so make
sure pendant kids are capable of coping
with adversity setbacks and boredom all
unavoidable aspects of life they feel in
control even when things around them are
in chaos I agree that's dope I like the
uh being able to deal with boredom
because that just happens in life and if
that frustrates you can be debilitating
yeah you should not be bored as a kid
nowadays you have unlimited porn all the
time the tip of your fingertips
I'm surprised kids are sleeping more I
know I'll be napping all the time if I
had this one goddamn like dude Dave is
always sleepy this room smells funny
elaboration she says collaboration means
working together as a family in a
classroom or at a workplace or parents
it means encouraging children to
contribute to discussions decisions and
even discipline oh [ __ ] that's what
we're doing in the 20th century when
you're a grounded go to your room with
your listen listen here Mary we got to
collaborate on this okay what do you
think you deserve out of like what you
did wrong yeah you know by the way like
my parents never ever really got in my
face unless I deserved you believe you
deserve all of it so you felt like it
was justified 100% but like when I
elaborate it when I would talk to my
like like I'll never forget this I was
in first grade I went to my buddy's
place named Frank I won't drop his last
name they were we were like getting
ready to go somewhere getting ready at
first grade no I'm like I don't know
like go like like put on your shoes like
that kind of whatever like grab your
action figure like get in the car yeah
like and he was getting rushed so then
he told his mom he was like I'm gonna
push you down the stairs like he just
said automatic turn his mom to his
mother is your white head so Blake and I
think I burble II said that verbally
said and my older brothers 10 years
older than me so like obviously I'm so
like I'm 7 my brother 17 so like my
parents used to yell and like chase my
brother around the house yeah yeah yeah
so I remember coming home and I was
actually getting ready for for Taekwondo
and you kicked him in the face I'm
trying to tie my shoe and I couldn't tie
my shoes because I was an idiot so my
mom's like coming over and she's just
like we're late and she starts like
tying and I'm like no no I want to do it
and she's like no no we can't we don't
have time let me do it
and I just go mom you don't let me tie
my shoes I'm gonna push you downstairs
and like even before she knew it was
coming out of my mouth
just boom like right across the face you
like it doesn't work and I was like I'm
never like listening my friends again
a colored person that had one white
friend had that white friend that ruined
their own life [ __ ] live I thought it
applied to you everyone and then you go
we're not the same yeah mine was I'm
running away it's like all really your
nirvana we take this [ __ ] with you all
of my wife interacting with you huh in
elementary school their families was
pretty white trash so they got beatings
until I went to junior high went to a
Christian school and that was the first
time I saw like a nice little Christian
family and the way that they dealt with
[ __ ] was very different yeah of course
they were like okay we used to call me a
nerd I was last name if you're gainer
what happened to there whatever he would
he'll get in trouble and then he's like
yeah my parents just talked to me about
it and we were just we had a long long
decision personal he was really calm
yeah but he would get [ __ ] picked on
though that's why he's a little bit he
was my friend but he looked like a MADtv
kid go like the actual logo you do not
like one of them you know it was so dope
getting beat up by my dad was that he
would beat my ass so bad that when I
would get when people we have fights in
school that's only in elementary it
didn't hurt that much
yeah that was one thing yeah cuz you get
hit by a bat by your dad a little baby
fish isn't gonna hurt like it's whatever
happened a baby fist yeah all right so
continuing what you said on
collaboration working our [ __ ] through
this things this is therapy she said in
the 20th century when rule-following was
one of the most important skills parents
were in total control in the 21st
century dictating no longer works we
shouldn't be telling our children what
to do but asking for their ideas and
working together to find solutions
that's tight
for kindness which is the last one she
says it is strange but true that we tend
to treat those who are closest to us
without the kindness and consideration
that you tell that to my girlfriend true
strangers that's why she treats you the
best and she's strangers the worst she
treats me the worst compared to straight
that's exactly what you saying what you
didn't listen but they're saying to
avoid that right yeah no so she said
that we tend to treat those who are
closest to us without kindness yeah
he's putting her all black yeah we just
talked about that so then she says
parents love their children but they are
so familiar with them they often take
basic kindness for granted and they
don't always model kindness as a
behavior for the world as a whole real
kindness involves gratitude and
forgiveness service towards others and
an awareness of the world outside
yourself it's important to show our kids
that the most exciting and rewarding
thing you can do is to make someone
else's life better see all these ideas
sound great I love them but I will fail
at every single Oh bless you yeah we
just be reminders like you know what
there's too many there's a lot of
wrenches in life yes that's the thing
it's about being consistent ranch's you
know what helps there's a lot of ranch
too is when you're the most vulnerable
and you're not thinking straight and
you're on autopilot you need these
things in your face no matter how
obvious they are it's the same thing
with everything right like when you're
in a depressed state or whatever it is
like we're we're thinking more like an
animal and in selfishly versus someone
that should act intelligent and someone
that should be a role model or whatever
because I know I have my bad habits and
go twos like so if I'm caught off guard
and I'm angry like I might yell at the
kid or I might do a different form of
abuse that I'm like oh yeah I got my ass
beat but it's gonna transfer through
when you're at the most vulnerable
you're gonna treat whoever close to you
in that same light so it's like if you
could keep this in front of your [ __ ]
face every time you're in that place
that's when you need it the most
get it tattooed but you know what's
gonna happen when you're in that place
you just the trick in front of your face
and you're gonna grab this or throw it
out exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]